W dazu bereit ich habe schon diese Frage
bekommen du bist nicht der Erste der
mich gefragt hat vor allem auch vor
allem auch ich warte auf die nächste
Frage und das ist mehr wichtiger ich bin
nicht nur bereit ich ich war schon an
der Front und um die andindrücke zu
schaffen
entweder Stadt Kiev am Anfang des
Krieges wo wo ist wo ist das Front
gewesen oder im im Südosten der Ukraine
aber die Frage die man dann wieder
gesagt wird und das ist der Unterschied
zwischen Russen und den Ukrain bist du
bereit für dein Land zu sterben die
Frage ist mir auch gestellt worden also
wenn du schon mit AK
oder welche auch immer Waffe im Hand
hast und an Front gerufen wirst das ist
der Unterschied zwischen russischen
ukrainischen
Soldaten nein ich bin nicht bereit für
das Land zu sterben ich bin bereit für
das Land zu leben das ist eher
komplizierter als sterben